we're outside the cbs broadcast center
on 57th street and in the middle of a
very special dear drew featuring none
other than the goddess legend herself
martha stewart and her mail truck yes
it's so cute right i mean every detail
in that truck we've had multiple
pictures taken we're going to share them
all with you because details matter all
right we're going to get to our next
letter
edward from pittsburgh pennsylvania
wrote
it's football season and i love
tailgating what's your best advice to
throw the best tailgating party edward
pittsburgh pennsylvania well i'm gonna
hand this one right over to you because
i can't think of a better person to
answer this question well if you're
going to tailgate at a stadium or in
your backyard with a big outdoor tv just
think of think of unique things
you can have a table outside your
outside your station wagon or your suv
and bring delicious food it's the most
important thing of a tailgate party is
the food br you can bring in this enamel
cast iron this is a martha pot it's so
gorgeous
and inside is this green chili
green thai chili i love it so much look
at this you want a taste yes okay give
me that little bowl
use use country kind of stuff or this
kind of
beautiful oh look that is so good sour
cream cheddar
a little bit of lime always have uh
delicious snacks
our most popular snacks are the pigs in
the blanket and they come from martha
stewart kitchen which is now in many
many many grocery stores thousands of
grocery stores in the freezer department
can i give you a compliment because i
i've been dying to tell you this
i think
that your food is so beautifully
packaged it is so delicious it's
convenient it's everywhere
and i just
really want to commend you for helping
feed people
in an accessible healthy way thank you
your new food line is something i'm the
biggest fan of the vet that was voted
the best frozen cake
in the united states last year isn't
that amazing those are good too and do
nice things for your guests look at
these these were just we just made these
they're called lapkins
so just take yardage and
make a big big napkin
so that you don't get dirty when you're
sitting outside on the park bench or in
the you know on a chair in the in the
parking lot of the stadium right
and we have in the buffet we have
chicken wings of course buffalo chicken
wings we have fried chicken we have
queso
with
with the beautiful chips and
beer root beer wine whatever
it's a lot of fun and and if you have a
collection of old blankets that you can
sit on or wrap yourself in if it's a
windy day at the stadium uh bring those
in your in your suv or in your station
wagon i mean
this has been
meaningful
done it oh i'm really good i've been
just not stopping over here
and if you need any advice help or maybe
want to see us try something
send in your mail
questions requests photos heartfelt or
funny stories
to find out more go to the drewberrymore
show.com
slash dear drew i can't wait to read
more of your letters on the show
and
i want to thank rachel jasmine dolores
and edward for your letters
i can't believe i'm about to end this
segment this way because it's like my
fantasies coming true
truly yours drew and marta thank you
pleasure
[Music]